uh buh panda way to a lack of no ideas
[Music]
so DC has announced another television
series that it is working on and before
I get into that let me note something
else so I did a video for my feelings
about the solo Super Bowl spot I am NOT
planning to do a separate video for the
full trailer which is getting released
today because they don't expect it to be
substantively different from that
trailer it's just gonna have more stuff
unless we see a ton of solo himself
which I don't think they're gonna do I
don't expect my feelings to change
significantly so I'm not putting up a
new video I'm also not doing videos for
the Jurassic world or the infinity war
Super Bowl trailers because both of them
just reinforce what I already thought
the Jurassic world one looked even
dumber than the first one done did in
the infinity war trailer made me go oh
okay yeah it still looks good but
nothing new to report there on either
one so that's all done out of the way so
metropolis DC is planning a Gotham style
show about the city before Superman got
there and as a fan of Gotham an
unabashedly
you'd think I would be if not on board
at least open to this idea and you would
be wrong so let let me think of how I
can explain this well first of all let
me actually back up and say I thought
Gotham was a bad idea and it wasn't
until about halfway through the first
season that I was started that I was
really getting on board with it it
wasn't until the second season that I
came to love the thing so even though
I'm a fan of Gotham now I was skeptical
of this concept long before and I think
it's even more questionable with
Superman than it is with Batman
cuz with Batman at the very least you
can go well there's a story to be told
about how bad Gotham was before Batman
got there because Batman effectively got
created by Gotham you can debate the
cause and effect as to whether or not
the costumed maniac showed up before or
after Batman himself but the city was an
absolute cesspool of crime and there's a
lot of stories to be gotten out of that
and we know that's what it was like
before he got there so there is
something there
metropolis is a perfectly functional
city before Superman got there I mean
Superman doesn't show up in Metropolis
because metropolis needs him I mean
really the world needs him he just
happens to be based out of Metropolis
there's nothing particularly special
about the city that demands Superman be
there it's it's just it's where he takes
up residence I mean in terms of going
way way back to classic well initially
he was busting up you know like slum
Lords in life so it was dealing with
urban problems they they created a fake
urban city but as his story sort of got
solidified more having him work at a
newspaper made sense because it put him
at the center of the what was at the
time the fastest way to get get it the
fastest way to get information about
what was going out of the world then the
things that might need him so you know
he's in an office where information is
flying around and he's got to get it
sooner than the general public is so
made total sense and you'd want to put
him in a major metropolitan one so you
make up a city this basically New York
and you put him there cool awesome well
what does he do with that city if he's
not there I'm gonna assume this whole
thing's gonna have a heck of a lot of
focus on Lex Luthor I think there's been
word that Lois Lane is gonna factor in
there as well so how much you want to
bet it's Lois Lane intrepid reporter
trying to take down Lex Luthor business
mogul which I mean
I'm not gonna say there's nothing to be
done with that idea but like that having
it be related to Superman adds nothing
to that concept you you could literally
remove the Superman references from and
just tell a a reporter has a vendetta
against a business scumbag TV show and
have it be anything but I mean I don't
know and now I'm talking myself out of
that because I at the same time that's
the kind of idea that might not go
anywhere unless you attach it to
something like a Superman related so I
guess I guess if I knew more about the
creative process if I knew like if this
was a concept that they are slapping
Superman on - oddly I'd probably be more
okay with it because I'm actually not
insanely adverse to ideas that are solid
but probably wouldn't get a look-in if
they were done as original IP getting
attached to an established name in order
to be given a shot I'm actually totally
okay with that as far as the general
concept goes but if they came at this
from an angle of let's do metropolis
let's do this show about the city before
Superman gets here and then this was the
best story they could come up with of
course I say that not even knowing for
certain that this is the story that they
came up with but I mean what what the
hell what the heck else is there to do
if you're not gonna do the Gotham thing
and bring the you know a lot of the big
villains in otherwise which in that case
if you're doing that you have to have
somebody deal with them and then you've
basically just started making Supergirl
without Supergirl herself and you'll
have a core team of people that you know
superhero stuff you've got your latest
or a fun Buffy and yeah and again I just
I I don't know what it is they think
they have it that is worth doing with
this basic concept
metropolis is only interesting because
Superman is there
Gotham is interesting for a multitude of
reasons and I mean this the city not
just the show the show is interesting
for a multitude of reasons too but you
know that's the separate thing
but I just don't know what they're
thinking with this and it really does
seem like they they have a weird mix of
idea folks over at DC cuz you you've
obviously Berlin sees actually out these
days but you've got the folks behind the
you know still running the arrowverse
they've gotta got their own little
pocket black lightning isn't technically
connected to that but it feels born of
the same kind of thing
Gotham is off at its own wild tangent
completely divorced from all that and
now like what where does this metropolis
thing fit because I mean part of what
works about Gotham is that it is nuts
you wouldn't make metropolis nuts
metropolis is not a crazy City
Gotham is a crazy City it's a city that
is worth just diving into it seeing what
insanity can we get away with because
this place is insane why would you set a
show metropolis and like having to focus
be the city and the residents of the
city as opposed to the guy who saves the
residents of the city I just don't I
just don't know what there is to do with
this so I mean that's kind of it I mean
I just think this is a dumb idea and
given that I don't want people to assume
that I'm on board with this just because
I like Gotham and it's the same core
concept yeah I need to say my piece on
that but you know what let's be fair
does anybody out there have any idea for
what they might be doing and whether or
not it will work if you have an idea for
an angle they could take that could
actually work please by all means tell
me that even if you don't whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it and there's
all that stuff you can do you can
support me on patreon follow me on
Twitter podcasts and blah blah
a lot of links for all that stuff is
down below so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]